does it always go back to like the
government people that's why all this
stupid [__] happens is that pretty much
sums that's a pretty fair way of looking
at it that's a hot tap can wow can whoa
are you sure you want to say
[Music]
that a
squatter has won battle over a dead
woman's home won the battle won the
battle won leg legal ownership of a
property he took over and then sold the
home for a profit so it's way this is
some [__] California [__] dude it's
in the UK same thing same thing okay how
did this happen check this out so
there's a quirky ancient Roman law um
that was cited in this but let me first
tell you what happened there's a British
construction worker his his name is
Keith best and he happened to spot a
empty three-bedroom semi-detached home
in London's Newberry Park back in 97
while he's working in a construction job
nearby and according to reports he
started renovating the property and
ultimately moved his family into the
home in 2012 so he just started
renovating it and then moved right in
what the wow however the house belonged
to retiree Colin Curtis who lived in the
property with his mother until the late
'90s when he moved out now he inherited
the property but under what has been
described as a quirky ancient Roman law
that allows someone in possession of a
good without title to become the law
proprietor of the original own if the
original owner didn't show up after some
time so he got grandfathered in as the
home's legal guardian and an owner just
because the owner didn't show up they
didn't show up for how long so crazy so
he shows up and he takes it over in 90
in the '90s right like 97 you said
earlier yeah and this no nobody showed
up for a decade wow yeah so the guy
probably died the at least 10 years had
passed with without affection action by
the owner and effective action by the
owner and that's what made this guy win
I mean that does feel like an abandoned
home well we have that here too it's how
many years does it take probably two
months in
La same day same day it's like you go
shop for groceries and you come back in
a squatter took your house you're like
[__] man same day squat you know how
they're battling squatters now how what
now this is kind of like to me it feels
like some badass Mafia [__] right but
like so like say you got a squatter
you're like Joe help me out and I'm like
all right well just rent it out to me so
you write me out a lease I just wait
till they leave the house and as soon as
they leave the house I move in I bring
all my [__] in whatever and I just
become an obnoxious [__] roommate all
right yeah and then usually it's like a
really big six-foot dude that's like I
don't want to shower but I'm going to
walk around in my boxers and I'm going
to eat cereal be obnoxious and then
people are just like [__] I got to get
out of here wow and then that's how they
do it that's solid I heard about the
music thing where they blast music in
the room like just hanging out blasting
music just keep throwing Sono
speakers dude just have Anthony Lee go
in the room and sit down and the guy's
like oh [__] sake [__] I got to get the
[__] out of here dude sick of this [__]
that right now can you load the cabinets
with the sick of what an just but no
imagine imagine Anthony just going in
the room and then sitting down and then
that's like I mean that guy's got to get
it's crazy that like the house got
passed down it's your mom's house and
the house got passed down to you it's
yours you used to live in it and then
like something happens you move across
yeah you move across town or whatever
and then you come back like 10 years
later and you're like the [__] it's not
mine yeah dude 10 years to not go back
to a property that's why you need a
manager right a property manager to
constantly like check that is absolutely
why you need that yeah just leave the TV
on with K's videos running or
something 10 years is pretty crazy 10
years is crazy the TV is like let me die
please let me
[__] pull up PL I can't do it
anymore like oh my God was he just
paying the bills remote cuz I'm like if
you don't do anything and pay for
anything like doesn't the city come
after you and I don't know or maybe he
was paying for it but he wasn't like
effective action by the owner to take
control of the property is what they say
it doesn't exactly say what that means
but yeah that's what they're talking but
it's the crazy part it's yours right
like imagine like you bought just land
not even a house let's say you own a
piece of land in Texas and then 10 years
later there's like wait there's how come
there's a house here oh there's no one
here so I built one on top of this land
you're like no but that land's mine
that's crazy but you w't here to claim
it yeah right and he also said that he
thought it just transferred to him yeah
he didn't know he had to take legal
action to to Minister his mom's estate
sure he thought it was just like hey
transference because she died that's
pretty ignorant though because for most
things you have to like do some
paperwork so to make it binding so
that's kind of funny that's a lot of
bread so was he just a kind of like a
rich kid that just doesn't know anything
could be little scatterbrain isn't it
crazy how like uh like squatters and
stuff it's kind of makes you feel like
it's still the Wild West in in some ways
of the world you sometimes you think
rules aren't even [__] real dude
feels like they're real but only because
there's people that say they are yeah
like you could just they're not actually
there start remodeling a house that you
don't even live in it is kind of funny
that like [__] you're putting money
in Sweat Equity and a [__] yeah I'm
going put a sink in this [__] place
it is a little bit odd that it kind of
looks easier to acquire property like
illegally than it is legally buy a house
there's a lot of things you can acquire
easily like dude that's he chose right
he chose right on that house I mean I
mean he cuz he was doing construction so
he's there every day you know he's like
bird dogging it for a while knows the
deal yeah he's junkyard dogging that
[__] from across the way yeah you guys
heard of a professional renters there's
nothing professional about them okay but
they are like con artists right they'll
look for like you know how like there's
adus or like there's like a like some
people have a home and then they convert
their garage or whatever to like a
studio or whatever right what's an AD
stand something something unit addition
additional dwelling unit yeah yeah and
then they'll look at it and then they'll
say this one isn't registered with the
city right so they'll they'll say oh I
guess you're renting it out right so
they'll get a lease with you they'll
move in and then maybe a month or two
they'll stop paying rent and then they
go well technically I'm not even staying
here this doesn't even exist so there's
this conflicting law where the land lord
doesn't want to report because it's also
an illegal unit but at the same time
they like there's this weird
technicality where it's like they're
living there but they're not living
there and they can't get evicted because
it's also illegal to someone yeah so
they you just have this guy living wow
I'm like it's so [__] bold that
someone would do this because they
haven't met the vandalizing Avatar such
as
myself I will use the your own Adu I
will use all elements to get rid of this
guy Which element would you think would
be I think [__] you take I think I would
first use air which is which is noise or
smell noise or smell to get them out cuz
I don't want to damage my own property
right so that's air is number one Earth
is number two I would use [__] manure
whatever [__] bending so cuz I could
clean the [__] right yeah and then could
always be clean clean the [__] I think
flood water bending I think that would
still work you could just flood the [__]
out of their place BL effort dude you
you know what you can do is you get
while they're inside air conditioners
with the remote but you can only control
it with a remote so you crank it and
make it super cold and they're like [__]
man but if it's whm Hoff what am I going
to do they're not dude it's very popular
these days Wim Hoff is a popular method
you just make it freezing cold for them
it might be a Siberian [__] con
artist so they might like it cold but
turn it up if it's a Polynesian I think
oh you know what I mean we could you
know freeze them out tongin can't stand
the cold yeah genetically they just
can't do hope they I just play this [__]
and then I don't have to do any of your
guys'
work I mean what would that be
considered I uh eye bending torture
torture yeah that's
true eye bending I makes no sense I know
I don't know dude what made you pick
that video that one yeah oh cuz it says
Arena China China China China what would
you guys do do if um what would you guys
do if you had a squatter that was like
let's say you had like a house and
another little house next to you and
then they squatt it and you have to see
them every [__] day oh do I get my
dogs and they just bark all day they
just [__] bark and they would make
annoy them oh yeah dud I get my
neighbor's Nutcracker thing that
goes have a fan that's it that's it
that's what I do right by their [__]
window damn huge Nutcracker does that we
we were living in this complex and the
and the bottom floor was getting kicked
out and what this fool would do is run
the water and play Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles like the game and leave it on
repl and then just leave it on and leave
the house I'll leave I was going to say
how does he do it and then the run the
water just leave the water running
doesn't that the water doesn't the water
bill go crazy or something and then you
know what it is it's cuz the agreement
for where we were living the landlord
pays the water we pay electricity so
he's
screwing them hard so he just leaves all
the water on so what my roommate did is
just shut off his water he went into the
piping shut off his hot water shut off
everything yeah cuz he knew where to
control it from the garage area that's
dope turn off his [__] power too the
fact that you have to people have to
deal with this is nuts it is it's
[__] annoying and then one time when
he when he left um somebody basically
jammed a key in his door and broke it
broke it and so he couldn't open his
door bro you got to replace the whole
thing I would murder somebody I think I
would go crazy I don't have the
selfcontrol to deal with that I saw a
news story about a guy he I think he's
still fighting this battle but he has a
he owns a small home that is currently
occupied by squatter so he can't get in
but then that used to be his like
additional home that he used as an
investment his real house got foreclosed
on cuz he ran into some tough [__] and
lost his home he's homeless and he can't
get into his other house
that's unfortunate he lives on the
street and he still owns another home
but the guy squatting hasn't paid rent
and uh the bill collectors for utilities
are coming after him what the the [__]
cuz under his name bro you should be
able to go in your house and drag that
[__] by his neck on top of that
the guy that's squatting listed it on
Airbnb and makes money renting and
Airbnb approved it no way how does that
how he doesn't have the title to the
house or anything this California [__]
yeah dude that's why see it almost it
almost serves you just to be a piece of
[__] more sometimes it at this stage in
this climate in this state absolutely
but doesn't Gavin Newsome get style
points yeah he does great hair he has
nice hair great suits guy wears pin
stripes very well little is it him that
made all these things okay like who's
the [__] that said hey all the
da stop Prosecuting like I don't
understand you can make do [__] that's
what he doesn't play the tuba but he can
get get them to play what he wants them
to play yeah and I'm wondering fired a
prosecutor in Florida for not doing
their or da in Florida for not doing
their job yeah he's the conductor he
makes the flutes play the flutes he
makes the CL he's not doing anything to
push them to do it he's just letting his
the soral puppets win does it always go
back to like the government people
that's why all this stupid [__] happens
is that pretty much sums up that's a
pretty fair way of looking at it that's
a hot take can wow can whoa are you sure
you want to say that sure about cuz like
aren't people supposed to be able to
vote on certain things yeah but we V
[Music]
we